thank you
[Music]
so there was this Brazilian woman who
fell in love with a ragdoll that her
mother made her a ragdoll so they got
married oh what a legally Legally got
married Brazilian woman and then they
legally welcomed a child how sock puppet
feel free to he knows about socks feel
free to you know make your uh hypothesis
you know that they're sex dolls for
women available why does she marry one
of those
um maybe she does I'm pretty sure she's
familiar with the doll scene when it
comes to uh Partnerships let's let's go
ahead and put some uh faces so there's
documents backing up this Union her mom
made a that's a massive dog I was
thinking something smaller her mom made
this and she married it that does not
him it I I don't know I don't want to be
offensive what so does she get all the
tax breaks from like marriage and all
that stuff oh that's a good idea that's
a really good place we should ask Market
briefs that's a good question
he says no [ __ ] way because he's a
dependent well that's a whole other
country so maybe there's but not only
are they married it's he's a dependent
so oh she has to take care of them oh
yeah maybe she should get money from the
government too the kid too we don't know
who takes care of who right that's the
emotional no I think we know no yeah we
know you can't be making assumptions you
know it's a different this is a
different area of the Earth you know
that's the difference things turn
different down there you know what I'm
saying so this one woman I'm gonna
butcher this name maryvonne maryvone I
don't know Rocha just know in Brazil
ours are yeah okay
that sounds Eastern European bro
like Royce is
hot they already have H that's the r you
say the age of the r really no anyway
she's 37 years old from Brazil
hippopotamus she met the love of her
that's very very childish she met the
love of her life after complaining to
her mom about being single and having
nobody to dance with you know so her mom
made that Whitney Houston song
she couldn't find nobody to dance with
that's crazy yeah so her mom created
Marcelo the rag doll and uh it was love
at first sight as the parent enjoyed a
whirlwind romance very very clearly love
is the first I think they match
um they got married and not wanting to
have a baby out of wedlock the pair
decided to get married the ceremony
she's like Mom what a [ __ ] him so bad
which was attended by 250 people 250
people showed up for this having spent
their week-long honeymoon at a beach
house in Rio de Janeiro the couple
waited anxiously until their offspring
arrived they adopted a baby 250 gave
birth in just 35 minutes at home with a
doctor and nurse on site while live
streaming the event to an audience of
200 people how do you live stream a
birthing event like what happened my
brain's gonna explode dude
this is ridiculous everybody let's let's
be very happy and congratulations all
around dude wait is that Pinocchio's
what is that this is a joke what this is
this is JK news but this is a real this
is real news bro people coming for the
news what do you think from this season
looks crazy
this is for Real how are we allowing
this this should be illegal this whole
thing should be illegal just like an
example of like hey go ahead of society
like trying really hard to accommodate
someone's like mental state oh yeah
like they're all and they don't want to
shake her up so they're just like
playing along till death do them part
yeah I guess so I'm surprised this isn't
in Japan
I feel like my people people should be
doing [ __ ] like this they do don't they
marry Brazil I think they do don't they
marry the pillows the like I mean they
marry would you say [ __ ] robots look
how happy everybody is
would you throw the after party to this
thing I'm going to the club does he need
ideas
the reception
I don't know man what's your business
plan for this yeah he's gonna patent
this guy so it makes him whole
waterproof or let's let's say let's say
that there's a thing I bet you they have
an Instagram page yeah right I bet you
they're monetizing this I mean like if
they got on the news
uh how did they get on the news it has
to be some people just want love you
know yeah like what's the rationale
right would you count that as another
Resident if they're moving into one of
your properties
I mean if it counts as a spouse right
that's two plus right now for sure
despite living happily as a family
marivan says she is struggling to pay
the bills as the only Breadwinner okay
this fool is lazy he's not he's not
getting out there
watch they have a divorce
they have to go to court he owes child
support yeah
she wants to televise like the Amber
Heard trial she said based off her
wedding and uh you know uh the day of
welcoming her newborn baby in the world
it was a wonderful day for me very
important very emotional uh he is a man
I always wanted in my life married life
with him is wonderful he doesn't fight
with me
he doesn't argue and he just understands
me Marcel is a great and faithful
husband he is such a man and all women
envy him what material is he made out of
yeah yeah Tempur-Pedic canvas fingers
crossed I hope polyester that'd be tight
he's the perfect I gotta show you guys
more photos these are just I just love
what's the racket though what's the
angle here there's something there's no
limits how far this can go I don't know
what you guys are surprised like it's a
joke because a judge also like approves
of the marriage or dude doctors were
there doctors agreed there was a cake
dude I mean I'm sure if you're gonna pay
somebody look how much tradition and
culture is going on she's like smearing
150 people went to this they spent their
afternoon doing this she smeared cake on
them either now she's wiping his tears
away I don't I can't tell which one it
is so she's got to be in on this like
it's almost like a performance art yeah
kind of thing that she's like living out
right there's no way she really like
what are you talking she's just in love
guys it's Marcel because you know why
because if if this was discovered years
later having happened I would believe it
but if they're live streaming it as it
goes then you know they're like doing it
for cloud yeah yeah yeah how often does
he get dry cleaners
is that considered inhumane to like
throw them in like a washing machine I
don't think so I don't think it's
necessary especially if she threw like
cake on his [ __ ] face you know that's
true I don't know anymore if this is for
performance or like she's actually I
know because it's like I said it's
they'll check it do they have an
Instagram yeah look it up should I look
up they don't have an Instagram maybe
she's doing it because it makes her
really happy yeah that is good well I
mean if she if she's already like
struggling as the only Breadwinner at
campaign it doesn't seem like she's
capitalizing on something about it you
know right but at least they're low cost
the kitten has you know they don't eat
it is low cost or it could be a really
expensive like no I don't know or the
fabric softener must like costume I I
already don't understand what's going on
I'm like if I try to explain the story
to my dad I don't even know how he would
take it he probably punch you in the
face he's like is this one of your
friends is that what you guys do
this is Joe is Joe doing this did Joe
marry a ball is Joe a doll just say it's
Joe we that should be a segment on JK
news where we try to explain the news
to our parents
and they'll be like what the what is
that even right now I'm on a diet right
and I'm in the kitchen and I'm like
waiting my foods have to hit certain
calories my dad saw me putting food on a
scale and literally he was like that's
the pussiest [ __ ] I've ever seen in my
life your dad knows pussiest I'm like
putting like chicken on I'm up too much
to get off putting it on I think my
dad's like what the [ __ ] is that oh my
God I don't even know how to explain
this with this disappointing face and
[ __ ] does your dad like eat like the
same thing every day he can he's crazy
he can he's crazy says the guy who's
[ __ ] picking up pieces of chicken
he's crazy to the gram you know so she
says when my mom made Marcela and first
introduced him to me uh or me to him I
fell in love with him it was love for
Sight it was because I didn't have a
four-row dancer I would go to these
dances but wouldn't always find a
partner then he entered into my life and
it all made sense the wedding was a
wonderful day for me very important very
emotional it rained a lot but it was
wonderful so she really just needed a
dance partner like literally I'm looking
at a bunch of photos where she's just
hanging out with oh this one's good dude
he just like flop I just carry him
around like Weekend at Bernie's
like can't hold himself up
do you think she just adds on a beard
later or like a little like draws down
with a sharpie or like like uh it was
like Mr Potato Head she's got different
accessories just in a closet so you
should wear this today yeah she got that
that strap too that's what worries me
that maybe her mental states that
fragile that everyone's like don't even
say that oh like everyone's like
everyone's at the wedding
dude that's crazy it could be the worst
um the worst pairing you know like some
parents are very like nurturing and so
they don't want their kid to ever get
hurt and then there's also the kid that
might be like extremely sensitive so
starting from even like one years old
it's already been like oh don't do that
don't do that no no her friend is real
right guys her friend is real it's like
the first time you you tell another kid
that Santa's not real yeah like when
you're kids and then there's like an old
like you're already at the age where
you're like dude are you [ __ ] serious
that was not real how is this not real
guys he dresses up pretty nice though
look she's got a bump oh she's pregnant
she's he's putting it so close to his
face dude look
I'm just pregnant he's like that's a
bump dude this is the real deal this
honestly is kind of a we've done a lot
of weird ass news here but this one is
really like she's either a great comedy
like performer or like she I just want
to meet this person now or her Vlog is
just like I'm more interested in how the
law like allowed for all that yeah but I
mean in the States you could there's
certain States you can marry animals
really yeah where are those States but
they're like iguanas you can't marry
them the horse is okay though which
state can you marry upholstery though
it depends on what the the upholstery
identifies with you know what I mean if
they identify as an upholstery that
might be weird but if they're like I am
Marcelo yeah a throw pillow like who can
one say you know we did a JK news on um
that lady who married the train station
in [ __ ] San Diego
yeah it's the Amtrak station that's
pretty baller though I think that's
that's pretty cool consent they didn't
and that's that's what the contention
was by the bells
and I don't even know if it was like
like a like what do you call it like lit
like legitimized by the state but the
way that she would make love with the
train station is when the train would go
by and it would shake and Rumble she
would touch the walls and she would get
an orgasm back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]